hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday October 21st 2019 what's
going on how are ya how are you man
how's your goddamn day going in that
type of [ __ ] I woke up I woke up in
such a good [ __ ] mood I just I just
blew a gasket yeah what else is [ __ ]
knew how many gaskets do you have left
bill you know for like the last 10 days
these [ __ ] Google [ __ ] every time I
go to open like my [ __ ] email there's
like I swear to God like eight different
security like things I have to click on
and then go through all of this crap
basically to give them a permission to
monitor me
it's unfuckable iam of course I hit no
to as much as I can to try and figure it
I still haven't worked my way through
the whole [ __ ] thing and I know
there's all this a fine print and all
the [ __ ] I just don't I don't understand
what people's fascination is with spying
on other people like how [ __ ]
paranoid your [ __ ] Google I think you
got it wrapped up which is gonna do if
just to let you know hitting pile of
pause I can't say no I can't say no stop
[ __ ] paying attention to me you
[ __ ] weirdo follow me down the street
you know I can't say no best I can do is
pause it and then they go just to let
you know by hitting pause you know it's
gonna be a little more difficult to look
up some of the YouTube videos you've
already seen before it's like hey [ __ ]
I know what I want to see and I know how
to type what does that take me an extra
four and a half seconds to write Stevie
Ray Vaughn tightrope Austin City Limits
how [ __ ] long does it take to [ __ ]
type that as opposed to having you
[ __ ] weirdos I don't know I just
don't I don't [ __ ] get it
I don't get it it goes right down to all
of these [ __ ] morons out there who
sit there and they watch CNN and Fox
News and then if you watch CNN all you
do is yell about Trump and if you watch
Fox all you do is yell about the Obamas
and the Clintons and people who [ __ ]
sit there and pay attention to the news
they think they're so goddamn smart
they're a bunch of [ __ ] morons I used
to do this bit miok getting mad at the
president is like when your flights
delayed and they're not giving you any
information and you start yelling at the
person behind the counter going I'm
never fly in your [ __ ] airline again
it's not that person's airline their job
is to tear tickets and to stand there
and get yelled at when [ __ ] goes
sideways but they're not running
anything the same way the [ __ ]
president isn't I get just don't under I
don't understand like how much little
money does the president have to make a
year before you realize the dude has no
[ __ ] power [ __ ] mouth-breathing
morons what because he doesn't have to
sit in traffic is it is that why we're
in all of these [ __ ] wars to go save
people to go rescue people who happen to
be sitting on [ __ ] gallons and
gallons and gallons of oil you [ __ ]
morons
is that why when a liberal bleeding
heart [ __ ] Democrat goes in there he
[ __ ] bombs more goddamn people with
[ __ ] drones than any Republican
everything jesus [ __ ] christ I swear
to god these [ __ ] news junkies if you
just say any any [ __ ] thing about
what's going on currently in the country
and they support Trump they'll be like
well Obama did is it's like talking to a
[ __ ] sports fan
I talked to some of the other day I was
just like you know something I can't I
can't believe the [ __ ] Giants got rid
of Tom Coughlin that was such a [ __ ]
dumb move the guy owned Bill Belichick
why the [ __ ] would you do that and you
know what this giant fan said well I
mean that's not as worse as what the Red
Sox did I think I really have [ __ ]
guy went to the Cubs I'm like yeah that
was a dumb move to what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about the Giants and you're
gonna do this did this tit for tat
[ __ ] horseshit I wasn't saying it was
the dumbest move ever what the [ __ ] does
Theo Epstein have to do with Tom
Coughlin so rather than addressing
something we're not we're now gonna
[ __ ] play the blame game all the way
[ __ ] back and then what am I gonna
talk about how the Knicks [ __ ]
through what's-his-face out of the
garden Charles Oakley then I do that and
then then well then what are we doing I
don't get it I don't I don't [ __ ] get
it I don't understand like how [ __ ]
long how many [ __ ] political
candidates are actually going to come
along that call out these corporations
and call out these banks and then you
allow these 24-hour news [ __ ]
networks to then say that they're
socialists half of whom a [ __ ] owned
by the same goddamn people who are
making money off of all of these [ __ ]
scams I just don't understand how long
people can sit there and fall for that
fall front I don't get it
and then I've seen this oh I'm off the
[ __ ] rails this week I swear to god -
and now living out here in LA you know
and going to New York and being in
cities like Miami and all of these
[ __ ] places dude I have to [ __ ]
tell you something like what is
happening to people right now this is
all basically people don't think the way
that I think therefore they're morons
that's what the theme is going to be
here because I'm air-quote enlightened
I'm thinking I'm beginning to see the
fallout of like close to 20 years
not even 20 years say like maybe I don't
know we'll say 12 years of social media
the effect that it has had and reality
television that has had on the average
person walking down the [ __ ] Street
like I gotta tell you something I went
to a pumpkin patch yesterday right one
of the great [ __ ] things that you can
do with your kid you go to a pumpkin
patch and then they have like a petting
zoo you know you learn stuff from the
goats right you see the young ones all
happy you see the [ __ ] older ones
that are all jaded saying it's all
[ __ ] we're never getting out of this
pen you know but the young ones have
hope right you see a lot of metaphors as
you're watching it right or is it a
simile I don't know so I [ __ ] walk
into this pumpkin patch okay this is
it's all about the kids right you go
into a pumpkin patch Halloween you're a
parent it's all about the [ __ ] kids I
show up to this [ __ ] thing by the way
it's a [ __ ] phenomenal funk this has
nothing to do with the pumpkin patch
it's about the people there my first
thing I walk in the first thing I see is
mom booty cheeks hanging out of a pair
of daisy dukes it's like you're a mom
where were the rest of your pants
I saw another woman she was walking
around she had on a [ __ ] leopard
print slip no bra just walk like walking
around like like that trolling for dick
and a [ __ ] pumpkin patch like what
are you doing and then the guys had like
[ __ ] like super expensive sunglasses
and [ __ ] sneakers and [ __ ] and it was
like the whole [ __ ] thing did you
ever back MTV Cribs right and all of
these these musicians you know half of
whom that was like a rented house and
they would have their whips and they'd
had their giant fish tank and like their
entire [ __ ] house looked like perfect
right down to the the selection of fruit
and the way it was placed into the thing
like ever
was ready for a photographer which by
the way I saw somebody that who brought
a photographer to take pictures of their
family that had literally like a
paparazzi level lens and then I'm seeing
all these people clocking that being
like oh we have to [ __ ] do that yeah
everybody was walking around looking
like a foot not everybody was a look
like there was this core group of people
that were walking around that looked
like a [ __ ] Instagram video our
picture or whatever I just I don't know
I didn't know what my [ __ ] point is
but like people are starting to walk
around and they look like they're
photoshopped and then not I I just don't
I don't underst I don't understand the
hot mom like walking around with your
Goods hanging out with your kids this is
what kills me that there was like a
husband there there was a dad there like
when do you let that go it's like it's
over okay you [ __ ] you got a guy what
do you still campaigning for and I don't
want to hear this horseshit course she
does I'm just I'm just saying I don't I
don't know I don't understand it [ __ ] it
was weird
I felt like I'm at a pumpkin patch and I
had this weird divorce Eve I like
swinger vibe to it you know
I don't know I don't know what the [ __ ]
I was trying to say that I just maybe
it's just a way that I went out to
dinner this past week you know my lovely
wife and I shut my phone off because I
don't want to be the guy on the phone
cuz I definitely do that I'm bad about
that not saying I'm perfect on all of
this so when he sat down I didn't have
the phone on and then everybody else I
noticed that
Donna Remy had their phone on and did
what I would have been doing if I had
the phone on and they're just sitting
next to each other not saying anything
staring at their phones and I'm just
sitting there gonna [ __ ] that's what I
look like yeah just I don't I had a
really weird week if we're going to a
restaurant you have the people next to
you you know they're talking about what
you just ordered and they're staring at
your food and you're just sitting there
going just ask the [ __ ] question then
they asked a question what did you get
what is that oh is it good yeah fine you
know I'll give you one please P [ __ ]
people did it the whole meal what is
this D like like I ordered something and
it was too hot too spicy and I go yeah
it's too hot and I hear the guy the
table next we go he said it's too hot
it's like do you work for Google is
there a reason you're spying on me my
phone it's [ __ ] rude you know but I
think that goes back to that Instagram
[ __ ] thing where people like you get
food and you [ __ ] take pictures of it
I started doing that and then I was just
like what am i doing why am I doing this
I'm not into food to this level
why am i taking pictures of this [ __ ]
food because I thought other people do
and this is what you do right why the
[ __ ] am i into this why am i into that
why am i into this I think it goes back
to you goddamn this this [ __ ] account
that I can only hit pause to they just
keep you know the big boys whoever's
[ __ ] getting all the goddamn money
right the Rothschilds are the [ __ ]
internet I just they just keep [ __ ]
pushing you down the same goddamn lane
why is my only option to hit pause why
can these [ __ ] guys sit here and read
my goddamn emails why am i dumb enough
or why were we all dumb enough
collectively to start communicating over
the [ __ ] Internet this is the dumbest
[ __ ] thing ever who came up with the
Internet Al Gore now who came up with it
I think all of these [ __ ] things
and this is obviously not a
groundbreaking thought it's just finally
dawned on me this is just all so they
can know exactly what you're doing what
you're thinking I don't know because you
know something this [ __ ] Google thing
it gets more aggressive every time it
used to be like hey do you want to make
it more secure give us your phone number
and I would opt out now you can't do
that
now there's it's like literally this 10
minute thing that I have to go through
and just basically say everything's
[ __ ] ok or it keeps sending me back
to this to the first [ __ ] page you
know back in the day when you sent the
letter out all you had to worry about
was some [ __ ] creep down at the post
office might hold it up to a light and
what the [ __ ] was he seeing I mean the
letter was folded over three times you
know and I don't [ __ ] know I don't
like the [ __ ] people tell it you know
I have this weird thing where I'm all
about the deal you know whatever the
deal is I'll go along with it I'm fine
with it but like when you start grabbing
me by the back of my neck and giving me
no [ __ ] option other than pause you
know what I'm bound to have a hissy fit
on my own [ __ ] on my own podcast
ladies what do you think about that
don't you think once you have you have a
[ __ ] kid and you're there you know
with your kid at a pumpkin patch why are
you stealing focus from your kid having
your titties hanging out of your [ __ ]
shirt you know actually you know looking
back the punk match I don't think it was
that bad it was just when I walked in
that was the first thing that I saw no
mana there was some mom and listen she
wasn't bent over she was standing
upright and her butt cheeks were hanging
out of her [ __ ] kind of a [ __ ] mom
dresses like that ever maybe on her
anniversary in the goddamn bedroom what
are you walking around the ass cheeks
hanging out well this old man ran
ever end I don't think it's gonna you
know half of these [ __ ] broads I
swear to God like I can't say that
they're dressing like hookers when I was
a kid but they're damn close I don't
know what it is it's uh skank chic is
that what is that what it is I don't
know but I gotta be honest with you
sitting at that restaurant and actually
finally turning my phone off and takin
my own [ __ ] nose out of my phone and
then seeing other people on their phones
and actually realize and what the [ __ ] I
look like I don't know it's just the
things he almost funny but before we sat
down now when we sat down before the the
the food stairs the Google food people
sat down there was this group of like
young kids you know in their 20s or
whatever and they were sitting there and
it was the end of the meal and they were
all just sort of talking to each other
all while looking at their phones with
the thumb going like scrolling before
like an uber pulled up and I was just
like wow man I am like I am literally
looking at kids now II look at these
kids today in their in their [ __ ] 20s
as far as like what the [ __ ] they do
versus what I did I actually kind of
feel lucky that I grew up without a
phone instead of the big like rotary one
because I was already dumb enough the
last thing I needed
I'm just trying it like I'm trying to
pay attention to some of this [ __ ] that
I five I sit here in the dumb [ __ ] that
I think of and then I immediately go to
my phone to look up that information and
just tap out of a conversation with my
wife like somehow it will bring up
somebody and then it'll be like how old
is that guy do you think I don't know
and then I put it in there and then
sometimes we both look it up and then we
just both sort of stopped talking to
each
each other and then the next thing you
know I'm on a [ __ ] going down a
rabbit hole to see who came out first
the Jackson 5 or the Osmond family was
actually the Osmond family I got to give
Keith Robinson [ __ ] about that because
he tried to say in sync and all of them
stole the let's turn our children into
professional musicians and ruin their
childhoods you know he was saying black
people deserve the credit for that and I
was like you know I don't know about
that he goes to Jackson 5 were the first
ones it was actually the Osmond so you
know what I'm calling him up I'm gonna
call him up and ruin his [ __ ] day and
say you know what you don't get credit
for being the first race to have parents
stupid enough to destroy their kids
childhoods by making them [ __ ]
rehearse 16 hours a day
doesn't that sound beyond evil and cruel
why wouldn't you guess white people do
you know what's funny and there's a
bunch of you guys right now listen to
this you probably just went on your
phone to [ __ ] look that up alright
whatever you know what I'm a flawed
human being you know I guess I draw the
line at [ __ ] I don't know you know
when your mom is dressed like a stripper
on the afternoon shift I mean I you know
but it's like it's so [ __ ] acceptable
but I can't get off the subject
my wife she watches those [ __ ] Real
Housewives and the way that these
[ __ ] broads are dressed and the way
that all this [ __ ] they're shooting into
their faces I don't [ __ ] I don't get
it
no other than dying being old is this
[ __ ] you know if you stop giving a [ __ ]
people start holding doors for you they
call you sir
like you accomplished something good
afternoon sir is there something I can
help you with like a pair of corduroys
we don't make those anymore old man all
right sorry
plowing ahead here plowing ahead plowing
ahead Oh Billy the old man the old man
who doesn't approve of any I'm not
listening I'm not trying to be that old
guy that [ __ ] shits on everything
that young people do I'm just I'm more
concerned I'm not saying you guys all
right yeah I don't think you dumber I
think with all this [ __ ] information
you can look up if you use it correctly
you're probably way more informed on a
lot of [ __ ] and you know back before the
[ __ ] Internet you know what was I
doing was I reading books no I wish [ __ ]
face riding on the hood of my buddy's
car is he had the wipers on and [ __ ]
swerving down the street trying to knock
me off the car that's what we were doing
reenacting Raiders of the Lost Ark I
guess well what the [ __ ] I was just
sitting there watching TV wasn't I so
anyway I've still been studying for this
[ __ ] instrument exam and I just keep
going back and forth from [ __ ] like
I'm never gonna pass this to I got this
so I'm never gonna pass this - I got
this I will tell you what is great is
I've been able to use the internet in a
positive way I've been I'm really
turning like Google's like what the
[ __ ] going on with this guy is I've
been watching all these videos on you
know different gauges and how to read
them and that type of [ __ ] and weather
maps and all of that I can't [ __ ]
believe I'm actually getting into the
weather it's actually fascinating now
now when I fly on planes I'm looking at
the clouds I'm trying to guess you know
at what level we're gonna start hitting
some turbulence if I see some cumulus
clouds at or below that level I should
start feeling some bumps right because
there's a lifting force
but if there's not enough moisture in
the air you won't see any cloud
development but the fact that the air is
clear you know that it's an you know
it's a chance that it's an unstable
atmosphere and it doesn't have a a
standard lapse rate I've actually gotten
into all of that going to like the winds
aloft [ __ ] this is the [ __ ] crap I've
been looking at and it's actually really
fascinating like I'm looking at this if
you go to the aviation weather Center
the graph of the graphical forecast for
aviation open your pages open your
textbooks to page 8 the fact that I can
actually [ __ ] read these things now
you know know what direction the winds
coming in how many knots it is I'm what
the gusts are to know what the
visibility is it's pretty [ __ ] cool
and actually kind of get into oli at
least these symbols and stuff as far as
you know the precipitation
look at this thing vor checks an ID
Private Pilot lesson just doing all this
egghead [ __ ] and I gotta tell you I'm
not really feeling any smarter but I've
been enjoying the [ __ ] out of it alright
let's start let's talk a little sports
let's get out of this [ __ ] let's get out
of [ __ ] uncle bill telling everybody
that they're wrong I'm not saying I
guess none of this [ __ ] is wrong yeah
maybe this is a part of getting let's
look at from your perspective a old man
you're just getting scared maybe that's
what it is just walking down the street
seeing all these laminated people just
kind of weirded me out
[Music]
but anyway I'm 47 weeks in to Nobu's
trying to go a year 52 weeks ladies and
gentlemen I am five weeks away I'm
almost to the point you remember when
Lance Armstrong would have the race
wrapped up and he won those [ __ ]
racist by the way the same way the
routed up Red Sox beat the roided-up
Yankees I mean everybody was on roids in
that race anyway remember when he would
be [ __ ] like heading into Paris you
know people are already congratulating
him there was no point to try to beat
him that day because he was so [ __ ]
far ahead I feel like I'm getting to
that week on the on the no booze and
[Music]
it's weird I wasn't thinking about booze
at all and then lately lately I did a
couple of gigs and afterwards I was just
like oh man but I like a nice glass I've
been having right now I did a great
[ __ ] gig up in Saratoga it was this
out outside like [ __ ] theater you
just outside was hilarious because it
was for it was pretty damn cold out I
came out wick wearing I had a jacket and
a hat on and it looked like it was kind
of like I never I think I performed at
Red Rocks one time I was opening there
was an animation festival there and I
got I got to do a set there didn't do
well but I did get to perform there so
me and Dean delray Dean del Rey by the
way Dean del Rey not getting opener
laughs this past Friday night was
getting headliner Jesus Christ this
guy's murdering same thing with Joe
bartnick in Asheville and it's right
where Paul virzi was right before his
special came out and I you know I lost
Paul verzino longer opens for me I'm so
happy for him he's moved on he's become
a headliner in his own right and people
are coming out to see him and I'm
getting all these emails like dude you
said you know I went out checked out
your boy you were right he was [ __ ]
hilarious he's absolutely killing it out
there and now I feel like I'm gonna lose
bartnik and Dean Del Ray because this is
the thing when I picked an opener I
picked people obviously that I liked but
also that I knew we're gonna be you know
working towards
being headliners themselves like I
didn't wanted like [ __ ] you don't
walk work with somebody that was just
happy to be open and for me that would
slow me down it would I would would be
depressing but the the other so it's
great to see these guys grow but what
sucks is eventually you lose him to the
road now they're out headlining so I'm
wondering you know cuz all those a lot
of comics that I you know watched when I
was growing up they had the same opener
for basically their whole career and you
know which is one way to do it but doing
it this way I don't I think it's a good
thing because I think it's gonna keep me
young as far as knowing who the new
people are out there but um you know I
got a few get few more gigs this year
coming up before I hit the road hard
next year I got a big year next year and
like almost everything is built around
sporting events it's going to be like
and I'm talking everything from college
football NFL NBA NHL MotoGP Formula One
Kentucky Derby I mean the horse racing
the whole [ __ ] thing I'm going out
and I'm doing a gig and seeing a
sporting event and then coming back and
I'm so excited where my hour is already
especially a couple bits you know the
bit I had with those chicks [ __ ]
yelled at me and I told to go [ __ ]
themselves near this big thing now like
the exact troop that was getting mad at
me is now coming up to me saying how
much they loved the joke which making me
feel real good so anyway so I'm 47 weeks
and did not [ __ ] drinking and all of
a sudden now I want to [ __ ] drink
again I'm going back through this thing
where I want to drink but however I had
like four people this weekend asked me
what I was doing as far as working out
and I just told my was like I literally
I just stopped boozing and I've been
watching what I've been eating because
I'm in rehab in my shoulder which has
been going great
I joined this gym where I can swim which
I'm telling you I'm telling you is the
old man move swimming it's amazing as
far as you know the lack of wear and
tear on your body and if I can give an
old man tip to all the laminated
Instagram younger people out there the
sooner you start swimming the better
your life is gonna be you guys who are
out there cross fitting and running down
the street carrying tables whatever the
[ __ ] it is that those people are doing
every time I look at that stuff and I
winced and here's the thing I don't give
a [ __ ] how [ __ ] strong and how many
abs you get the you are simultaneously
destroying your joints you're wearing
them out and you need your knees for the
rest of your life and your hips and you
show this trust me
I'm finding out the [ __ ] hard way and
swimming and granted there's a way to
get hurt and everything but swimming
it's like you're it's like you're
working out on the moon you know as far
as like I don't know it's weird cuz it's
totally exerting yourself while it's
like you've taken the gravity knob and
turned it down you know I don't know III
think I'm totally I'm 100% sold on it
alright bill shut up all right enough
with your [ __ ] [ __ ] about society
sorry and working out why not what else
do you know grandpa congratulations to
Honda MotoGP they win the builders
championship whatever they call it you
know ever built the best bike they won
in Formula One Mercedes won it looks
like you know Marc Marquez has already
won the championship in MotoGP and it
looks like obviously Lewis Hamilton's
gonna win again I don't know what I'm
gonna try to go to one race each next
year a Formula One I haven't been in a
couple of years and and my first MotoGP
race I'm gonna go to that one in Austin
Texas
cannot wait
cannot wait for that I'm literally gonna
freak out like the same way the one I
went to Formula One and I actually saw
the cars it's funny because the car has
become like celebrities just looking at
those things weekend and week out you
start to get to know them and stuff like
that and I can't wait that first time
they come around the track you know the
fit CEO so marques Valentino Rossi all
of those [ __ ] guys like I don't know
it's gonna be [ __ ] crazy it's gonna
be crazy so that's what I got going on
so the World Series is now in place you
got the [ __ ] Washington Senators who
knew who knew with them congratulations
to them and you got the Houston Astros
just an incredible series against the
New York Yankees Yankees showing a lot
of heart the young Yankees being down 3
to 1 as the Astros just imposed their
[ __ ] will three games in a row after
going down oh one to come back to be up
three to one the Yankee scared the
[ __ ] life out of them almost forcing
a game seven and I know there's a lot of
bummed out Yankee fans out there but you
know there's a that was an incredible
season for them and to lose the way they
did you know heartbreaking loss and
everything but just the heart that they
showed they're definitely going to be a
problem for my Red Sox I can tell you
that for the the you know the near
future and unless they make a bunch of
dumb moves which back in the day when
you had George Steinbrenner they would
have because he was he was inpatient you
know so he would just get frustrated and
[ __ ] trade away guys when he
shouldn't have the [ __ ] T hit pause in
this thing alright sorry I'm back come
back [ __ ] clear my throat sick of
doing it on I know his bugging people
doing that anyway and I
what the [ __ ] I talking about the
Yankees the Yankees and all of that type
of [ __ ]
so I think they're gonna be a [ __ ]
problem back in the day yeah George
Steinbrenner would get all inpatient
like I've always maintained that the
greatest thing because he always tried
to buy it and I feel like in the 70s
that was the move because that [ __ ]
dope out in Oakland wasn't gonna pay any
of his players so they all became
available and steinbart it was like I
will I'll [ __ ] pay him got catfished
Hana Reggie Jackson and all of those
guys and they ended up going back to
back in 77 78 and then I felt like in a
lot of ways the Yankees were like the
the 7475 like flyers or the flyer
organization where that's the way they
won in 74 75 and then they just tried to
they ignored how the game changed and
they just kept trying to win that way
and I thought the Yankees Steinbrenner
was like that's how we won so he just
kept trying to do that right through the
80s and then that weird [ __ ]
relationship he had with Dave Winfield
he ended up getting suspended from
baseball and that was the best thing
that happened to the Yankees because
they've had ridiculous scouting for a
hundred years that for whatever reason
George didn't have the patience to let
develop and I think if he didn't get
suspended
those five great Yankees that came up
Jeter Bernie Williams Jorge Posada
Mariano Rivera and Andy Pettitte I think
he definitely gets rid of Pettitte [ __ ]
he tried to get rid of pet it even when
Pettit showed he was a champion Jorge
Posada I bet he would have traded away
and then you know Bernie Williams I
don't think so obviously not Derek Jeter
but Mariano Rivera was sort of
struggling as a middle reliever he was
just sort of doing okay so who knows
what would have happened if that guy was
actually around over that [ __ ] they
would lose like three games in her own
he would like issue a statement
let me guess George you're not happy
with losing was really weird but his son
doesn't seem to have that like he's
actually being patient so that sucks for
me as a Red Sox fan because that's
really proven to be effective so
I don't know we shall see and then you
got the houston astros who did I call it
or did I call it I felt that they they
were pissed off the whole year that they
lost to the Red Sox last year and didn't
go back-to-back maybe a little bit of a
hangover God knows the Red Sox had one
this year geez
so it's really cool to see to see them
come back and then go up against the
Senators which is an amazing thing they
came out of nowhere they lost that kid
where that Bryce kid clown question guy
they lost him and somehow I don't know
where they have this amazing pitching
that I had no idea this is just typical
me I missed the whole season and then I
discover what teams are in October but
yeah October baseball [ __ ] rules and
a little disappointed with how out of
hand some of the Yankee fans got I've
never really seen that with their fan
base like they've always been aggressive
East Coast fans or whatever always been
like that but that was uh that was a new
level but I also know that that's not
most Yankee fans I was just sort of
bizarre it's almost like they knew they
weren't gonna win so they acted like
that you know it's [ __ ] frog in my
throat the hell it is getting up too
early here the old man didn't didn't
stay in bed long enough but I know
that's not all of them and God knows I
mean I can't as a Boston fan some of
this [ __ ] we've done I always loved that
- a real classy boss did keep it real
classy it's like what city has class you
know I'd say st. Louis they seem to have
really classy fence I would say that if
every person of color wasn't shoved over
in East st. Louis a lot of [ __ ] going on
down there if you hang out for a week
start to see it San Antonio Spurs fans I
think are really cool but generally
speaking yeah we're all a bunch of
animals all right and with that your LSU
Tigers win again they went again and now
they got they got two huge weeks coming
up we got Oberon next
week and then Alabama and what are we
six and oh seven or no and I do say week
cuz I do follow them I follow them and I
follow Michigan Michigan fortunately had
to go out to go do some stand-up that's
unfortunate but I missed the game I
forgot to tape it and I one of my
buddies who's a big Michigan fan said
they got a couple of tough calls early
but then late in the game they missed
some sort of holding call or something
like that on a big play but uh Penn
State look at Penn State they were
undefeated now when is Penn State play
Ohio State that is the game that I want
to see Penn State verse Ohio State 2019
when the [ __ ] is it this is the game
this is the game you got a watch I was
at the rivalry game 11:23 Wow Penn State
ranked six Ohio State ranked third
alright I got more [ __ ] sports to
talk here but I got to do the gonna do
the reads here actually had my the [ __ ]
is that I had it sent to a different
email account maybe this one will let
Matt Everett is it opened up okay oh
look who's here everybody it's old zip
hiring can be a slow process cafe l
Torre's co o chief operating officer
whatever have an executive Dillon
Miska wits Dillon Misco its I love it
look at that that's a millennial name
Dillon Miska wits needed to hire a
director of coffee for his organic
coffee company but he was having trouble
finding qualified applicants isn't
coffee beans aren't those organic those
are natural right they're not made out
of plastic so he switched to zip zip
recruiter doesn't depend on candidates
finding you it finds them for you it's
like a roadie at a rock show pointing
out all the hot chicks bringing them
backstage who's gonna be the winner
it's technology identifies people with
the right experience and invites them to
apply to your job so you get qualified
candidates fast Dillon posted his job on
zip and said he was impressed by how
quickly he had great candidates applied
he also used it recruiters candidate
rating feature to filter his applicants
so he could focus on the most relevant
ones and that's how Dillon found don't
found his new director of coffee in just
a few days it's kind of a cool job title
what do you do hey haven't seen you
since high school what are you doing I
am a director of coffee at Cafe El Toro
el Toro Wow six figures with results
like that it's no wonder four out of
five employees who post on zip get a
quality candidate within the first day
that can't be the end of the copy it is
where the [ __ ] the rest of it go to
zip recruit accom / / that's zip
recruiter com / / am I pretty sure
that's what it is
alright untuck it alright oh my god this
is this is this is a good idea ever
wonder why traditional button ups look
so long and baggy that's because they
were never meant to be worn that way
exactly untuck it shirts were
specifically designed to be worn
untucked I love these [ __ ] shirts
because you can wear them untucked and
they also keep you in shape okay because
when you wear and untuck it if you're
kind of a fat [ __ ] it your ass crack is
going to be coming out the back when you
squat down to pick up your keys or maybe
that's what you want to be showing it
the [ __ ] pumpkin patch maybe that's a
new millennial thing you want to show if
you're waxed man butt crack
yeah Botox butt crack I'm getting rid of
the wrinkle in my ass untuck it it's the
brand you've been looking for it's the
original untucked shirt a modern
solution to an old problem what is it
amazing it took something somebody so
long to come up with this idea
considering people have been wearing
their shirts untouched since the grunge
era which was almost 30 years ago with
no talking or tailoring required by the
way the day they play a Pearl Jam or a
[ __ ] Jane's Addiction or Nirvana
whatever the big bands were out there
Jane's Addiction was the best by the way
I know they always talk about the
Seattle band but changes come on there
was no that ritual album smokes anything
that any of those other bands put out
I'm sorry they just says but the day
those bands are played on an oldies
station the generation of music after my
generation of music I'll tell yous gonna
be a rough one all right no matter your
size or shape their shirts are perfectly
untucked length oh so maybe maybe they
they add extra material if they if they
get like a wider body thing they figured
it out right they think that they
designed it all right you got some big
[ __ ] hips in you [ __ ] you know you
squat - a [ __ ] phone right your butt
crack doesn't come up motivate or it
doesn't get exposed think what that's
like you know where the pants go down
and the shirt comes up it's like an old
what do they call it a dummy waiter you
know that thing [ __ ] it opens up you got
to watch out for that backfire is on my
mind motivate your audience talk about
your personal experience with the
product of the service I just did I love
it it looks cool and it keeps me in
shape anytime I feel that cool breeze
going down my san andreas fault there I
know I got to lay off the [ __ ] creams
sickles I'm happy have you been
frustrated with shirt buying in the past
how is yeah every time if you wear like
a regular shirt that's designed to be
tucked in you wear that untucked you
look like the [ __ ] roofie guy at a
[ __ ] corporate Christmas party like
Jesus he's our
that hammered it's 11:00 in the morning
what do you like most about untuk
compared to the other brands it looks it
looks like it's supposed to be untucked
okay enough with the questions what are
you Google huh you're gonna [ __ ]
figure out all my personal information
about my shirts with more than 50 fit
combination untuck it shirts look great
on tall short slim and athletic guys of
all ages try it on in person didn't say
fat try it on in person I guess you
can't say fat can't you say husky is
husky like politically incorrect I mean
let me only actually look that up after
this read here the politically correct
way of saying fat what would they say
hybrid hibernation a life or something
hibernation wait I'll try it on in
person at one out of untuk it's 50
stores or go to untuck it calm to get
started they even offer free shipping in
return on all orders in the US you can
save 20% on your first order by using my
code birbee you are are a check a check
out that's untuck it calm let's check
out these shirts oh my gahh these these
are the ones these are beautiful you
know what god dammit god dammit I'm
gonna have to get some of these [ __ ]
things
those are good stage church too you know
what the big thing too is you gotta
[ __ ] you got to get a goddamn well
they have a Los Angeles location look at
me I'm literally shopping in the middle
of my [ __ ] ad reads here now watch
every [ __ ] advertisement we like it
when bill goes to the website during the
read and says he's gonna buy the product
I actually finally learned how to iron a
shirt one of my buddies I go out on the
road with used to be in the Navy he was
watching me iron his shirt and it was
driving him nuts he goes I I can't I
can't watch you do this
you know when your shirt gets shiny I
never realized that like I was ironing
the wrong side of the shirt you're
supposed to iron the inside of the shirt
you know and like the part of the collar
like I was earning the inside of the
collar but it folds down and that's what
you're gonna see so I have a shiny
collar and my shiny man tits coming out
on the [ __ ] stage he turned the thing
inside out he hired the right part of
the collar you know the part that gets
that you don't see and I guess he when
he was in the Navy if he came out with
shiny [ __ ] shirts and pants and [ __ ]
like that you'd get I don't know what
there you go peel potatoes whatever the
[ __ ] they do keelhaul yeah
whatever they do in the Navy alright
stamps.com everybody you know what I
hate more than anything man being
bothered with little daily annoyances
why are they speaking for me I mean
they're right but and I don't like this
you know what I'm talking about this is
like a T stand up here you know boy you
ever notice daily annoyances really
bother you hey this guy knows what I'm
talking about being stuck in traffic
waiting in line going to the dentist
difference between cats and dogs are
just having to do things I don't have to
do well guess what I can get rid of some
of those annoyances just by using stamps
calm you know about stamps calm they've
been sponsoring the show for over seven
years is that right Wow seems like just
yesterday and if you haven't tried it
what are you waiting for the holidays
are coming up quickly and gets tatted
with stamps calm today so that you are
ready for the holiday rush stamps calm
brings all the services of the post
office right to your computer you can
buy in print US postage for any letter
any package right from your home off
home or office now you can even schedule
a pickup with the mail center so you
never have to deal with LA traffic like
me or wherever the hell you're at going
to the post office alright I haven't
even gotten to the best part yet with
stamps calm you have five cents off
every first-class stamps and up to 40%
off Priority Mail why would anyone pay
full price when they don't have to
right now my listeners get a special
offer that includes a four-week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale
without any long-term commitment just go
to stamps comm click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage and type in
brr-brr that stamps comm enter ber
stamps comm never go to the post office
again alright before I get to the
questions for this week I got a talk
about the Baltimore Ravens you know I
got to give them props going into sneaky
peeks palm look up this guy's [ __ ]
name I don't know a quarterback what the
[ __ ] his name what the [ __ ] is this
guy's name Lamar Jackson I mean they
basically were making it out like this
guy single-handedly went in there and
beat the [ __ ] Ravens I mean he did
that there the Ravens defense was great
and this Lamar Jackson guy was just
running all over the goddamn field and
you know what they hyped him up once
again as they always do with the running
quarterback and I got to ask you how
many times can you [ __ ] see this how
many times does it have to go the exact
[ __ ] way it always goes in the NFL
NFL and these guys on ESPN I get it now
their job is to sell me the game this
guy was trying to make this argument and
he made a very convincing argument that
he actually felt that that
what's-his-face Lamar Jackson was
actually better than Michael Vick as far
as a running quarterback and he said
Michael was faster in a straight line
but this guy has more shake-and-bake or
something like that and what I wanted to
say was like oh you mean Michael Vick
the guy that they eventually caught up
to and then slowed him down with injury
he's a little different because he did
go to jail there for a couple years but
like least these running quarterbacks
they date there's a reason why a guy who
runs like Tom Brady as the success can
still have the success at that position
that he did you don't need to do what
this guy is doing and
if you do it long enough your career is
gonna be as short as a running back
rg3 and people like that it's like you
can't you can't be out there you can
only do that there's a finite amount of
time this guy is gonna be a pain in the
ass for [ __ ] three years doing that
and then you know defenses [ __ ] hate
playing against a guy like that and that
[ __ ] where you have the receivers
covered and there's nobody open and you
did your goddamn job and this [ __ ]
[ __ ] takes off and still gets 18 yards
it pisses them off with every [ __ ]
game it pisses them off more and more
and then one day you know somebody slows
you down and they get an opportunity to
take a hit and they [ __ ] hit you and
then that's all she wrote so he actually
looks like he can throw too so I don't
know I never believed in these types of
quarterbacks but you gotta respect the
Ravens having already having a [ __ ]
defense like they do when they lost Edie
Reed and Ray Lewis to come back this
quickly like they really are they've
established himself since they became
the Ravens like just one of those teams
that just always seems to have a great
defense like the Steelers for so long
the who else is another one that always
seems to have a great defense the Bears
and the Ravens have really established
himself since the you know late 90s
early 2000s it's just being one of those
teams so they look like they are going
to be a problem and the worst thing in
the NFL this past week was seeing
Patrick mahomes get hurt don't look at
that we have the Ravens is that next
[ __ ] week we played tonight Monday
night what state of 20th know that's in
a couple of weeks we're gonna play them
Jesus Christ that's gonna be a [ __ ]
tough game and where it looks like we're
in Baltimore ooh oh that's gonna be a
big game oh they fake [ __ ] is there
another wine and franchise that [ __ ]
[ __ ] devout us I cannot [ __ ] wait
until you know I give my admit I can
wait because I like continuing to win
but twenty years down the [ __ ] road
when they look back on Belichick and the
Tom Brady and all that I can't wait for
all these [ __ ] football coaches and
owners that wind in all of that [ __ ] I
really want to see them still bitter you
know it's the best that they could come
up with like a little error they were on
your field looking at us the [ __ ] up
bunch of goddamn broads you're not
you're not as good as they are okay
[ __ ] step up your game all right
let's get into the but anyways
congratulations to Ravens I wish I
actually was I was studying yesterday so
I didn't I didn't watch any of the games
my team wasn't playing and I just
decided [ __ ] DIRECTV they still have
given me the [ __ ] NFL package and at
this point I don't give a [ __ ] you know
I kind of like going back to only having
a couple of games why do I need all of
the [ __ ] games you know what am i
scouting for somebody I don't need to
[ __ ] do that [ __ ] although I will
tell you the great thing about having
the NFL package is you don't have to go
into a sports bar because barstool
sports as always posted hilarious video
they posted this video of of when the
Yankees lost on the walk-off by l2 vey
and there was one Astros fan in there
and just how obnoxious this guy was
clapping like I got to hand it to the
Yankee fans when they're that they
didn't turn around and [ __ ] punch
that guy who throws something I was
[ __ ] amazing it was hilarious but
it's why I don't go to a sports bar
because like watching them you the level
that you care about something that
really has no effect on your life it
doesn't it's [ __ ] ridiculous like
being a sports fan is literally a
[ __ ] disease and if you want to see
somebody bought them out on Skid Row
watch that [ __ ] barstool sports thing
it's it's one of the reasons why I don't
go to sports bars because it hurts
enough for my [ __ ] team loses I don't
need that [ __ ] guy
he literally announces the homerun oh
and that fitted your houston astros
they're going to the World Series it's
just devastating to these Yankee fans I
mean his level is [ __ ] talk was was tops
Johnny Walker Blue I got to give it up
to him it was phenomenal but it's also
why but having said that [ __ ] the NFL
package not [ __ ] the NFL package [ __ ]
these [ __ ] [ __ ] at DIRECTV what I'm
gonna do
I heard that YouTube you pay 70 bucks
you can get all the cable channels for
[ __ ] that you want I'm gonna do that
or whatever I'm giving in all right I'm
gonna have my [ __ ] butt cheeks
hanging out at a pumpkin patch I'm gonna
get some Botox and I'm gonna go get a
little [ __ ] iPad and I'm just gonna
I've already watched MotoGP on my on my
computer because they're not on Fox
Sports anymore so why not I'm just gonna
say [ __ ] I'm gonna watch it all on
that all right there we go
hot redhead alert hey Billy Brickhouse
long time female listener here I noticed
you always asked when is there going to
be a major redhead on the big screen oh
I always say that whenever the lead they
let us one time they gave ever extolled
some work and then they gave the guy
four NYPD Blue and he did Jade and it
didn't do well and then if they put us
back on the freckled bench when is he
gonna be the lead or any screen for that
matter other all right here we go
anyways there's a show on HBO called
billions amazing show you should check
it out the boss is a redheaded
billionaire he has brains brawn and is
hello a billionaire yeah but that's on
the show and it doesn't sound like he's
the lead either another redhead on the
rise is Oliver Stark he plays on a show
called 911 911 911 11 this guy gets so
much ass it's ridiculous he's super hot
I guess the ladies love is milky white
skin you're not the only one turning
heads Billy Boy yeah that's that that
ship is [ __ ] sailed keep up the funny
and we can't wait to see you for three
seconds in Star Wars
hey Nia with an end alright yeah you are
gonna see me very quickly by the way
that Star Wars comes out it's November
9th I think November 11th November 9th
and November 11th on Disney streaming
service and it's gonna be a juggernaut
I'm already having like Star Wars fans
coming up to me and I got to tell you I
really like them
they're nice they're respectful totally
different from my sports fan comrades
that I mean that those are the people I
am loved the podcast like that's how I
get that's what I usually get you know
it's funny is when I meet podcast
listeners around people that don't
listen to the podcast I've had that a
couple times I've been on acting gigs
and I'm walking over to play a fireman
or a cop what else am I gonna play right
something with a temper and I'm walking
over to go do my lines or whatever I'll
just be we know we're shootin wherever
and I'll walk by and they'll just be
somebody walking by the set and just go
depression with me is like that person
is a friend of yours it's AI it's a
podcasting that's how they talk to you
yeah it's actually endearing and when
they do it it makes me feel good it's
weird
alright movie influence dear pal with
all that talk about the Joker being a
bad influence on lonely white men what
that yielded no issues it got me
wondering a bad influence on lonely
white men they are really just reaching
for this [ __ ] on like this is why I kind
of tapped out I don't pay attention to
everything I've heard about the Joker is
it's a masterpiece and he kind of knew
once you know when they casted Joaquin
Phoenix I mean that guy's [ __ ]
amazing and then he gets to play the
Joker
it really is crazy how that role seems
to bring out the best
in people that were already amazing
actress all I've heard it's a met ism
it's a masterpiece I heard that and kill
the Irishman those are the two that I
want to go see anyways it's got me
wondering has a movie ever influenced
you to do anything yet they influenced
me to want to be in movies I guess even
if it's not something dangerous or
violent have you ever walked out of a
theater a different person no not at all
and I and to put that level of weight on
a movie is [ __ ] ridiculous you walked
into the movie theater with issues it's
the same thing they try to do is stand
up like the fact that you could like
walk in to a comedy club not
misogynistic and then listen to my act
and then walk out and then like hate
women or walk in not be homophobic and
then walk out in be homophobic or be
homophobic and then somebody tells a
joke that is supports gay people and
then suddenly you're not homophobic
that's it that's not how it works that's
how it works on dr. Phil oh you need to
stop being misogynistic I'm gonna do
that alright we fixed them it's like to
really change as a person it takes a lot
of work I mean I remember seeing you
know music videos as a kid and they
influenced me that I wanted to play
drums but I didn't immediately play
drums or like just walk out and I knew
how to play drums cuz I watched it there
was an unbelievable amount of work
involved to do that I mean I think
something can influence influenced you
to like you know maybe start you in the
direction of something but like it's
gonna wear off within 24 hours and then
it really comes down and then I think if
you stick with it it was in you anyway
if that makes sense yeah I just don't
like I listen to some of the you know
most lunatic comedians growing up none
of them influenced me to do anything
other than to want to be a comedian I
was into you know the art form I just
thought it was [ __ ] amazing
and comedians were amazing and I watched
all of these [ __ ] guys and like that
said all kinds of crazy [ __ ] I watched I
listened to Richard Pryor talking about
freebasing and lighting himself on fire
my parents told me to stay away from
that [ __ ] and I saw them everyday I
didn't live with Richard Pryor so I
never freebase cocaine or ever had a
desire to I didn't my parents told me
state that [ __ ] is the [ __ ] devil
stay away from it and they told me that
all the time
your parents influence you so I think
you can be okay I don't know it's a
weird sort of like you can be inspired
but like III really draw the line on
that it can make you a bad person I
think you came in like that or you were
[ __ ] up to begin with and and then you
go to court and you're trying to get out
of it so you blame a movie or Judas
Priest or something like that and then
you know parents co-sign on it because
they don't want to feel like they did a
bad job bringing you up I feel like
movies and comedians and [ __ ] like that
and athletes or scapegoats for bad
parenting or kids that were just born
that was just fun enough they they just
were born with something wrong with them
does that make any sense I don't know
and actually I remember there was a kid
that I knew in my neighborhood who was
really into Tom Cruise and whatever Tom
Cruise did he whatever his job was in a
movie he would then go out and do but
then like two weeks later he would quit
the job so he would get influenced and
he would try to you know I'm gonna be a
bartender that spins bottles around
Top Gun I'm gonna enjoy the ROTC and he
[ __ ] quit all of that [ __ ] cuz
eventually he had to find out who the
[ __ ] he was I think that's what that's
what you learn it's like oh wait I'm not
Tom Cruise and Tom Cruise isn't even
that guy he's just pretending to be that
guy I think I think they can like
influence you to try vo maybe I should
let me try this and then if you go there
but if the passion isn't there then
you're not gonna do it so maybe that
maybe that's what it is I don't [ __ ]
know
not a psychologist alright cruise ships
bill you're right about cruise ships
being floating piles of [ __ ] I never
said that I just said there's too many
people and I would sink them if I was
the dictator but you're more than right
but you're more right than you know all
it takes is 18 and the biggest class
cruise ships in the world to mash the
polluting power of every car currently
on the road please repeat sentence I
don't want to
what are you Google don't tell me what
to do now you can look it up people want
politicians know this of course and so
does the media but they're all buddies
with the rich guys that own the ships
but you also know it and I know it and
what are we doing about it we got to
stop using rich people and politicians
and scapegoats I really believe if you
want change you have to do it
alright I'm starting with and they know
it spilled over to Airlines Plus what
politician wants to tell the city
getting all the tax money from the port
that they can't collect dirty money
dirty Monday's what you wrote anymore
boo-hoo-hoo yeah it's bad the whole
thing is the the way politicians are so
I know they have their arms tied behind
their backs like I have actually empathy
for that position they're underpaid they
need money from these people and then
they have to do what these people say
when they get into office or else they
won't get reelected and then how do they
make it to the blood money tour that
Obama is on [ __ ] a bush and all of
these [ __ ] guys Bill Clinton's
all the clintons go out and just [ __ ]
give speeches to the same people that
donated to their campaigns the whole
[ __ ] thing is gross Jimmy Carter man
was the last [ __ ] human being look at
that guy he's out there building houses
for the [ __ ] homeless all these other
concert on the [ __ ] Blood Money Tour
alright carbon credits Billy boiling
water while people argue whether or not
climate change is real or man-made the
elite have already figured out a way to
make money off of it they're going to
create a system where countries
governments and eventually individuals
will have a limited amount of carbon
they can admit they'll get a certain
amount of credits which will be measured
by of course by a group of by a group
started by bankers they're going to
create an exchange and trade these
credits the way they trade real estate
bonds government bonds and gambling on
futures so a country like China will
sign on to something like this knowing
that they can buy credits from someone
not using all dares and pollute even
more dude where the [ __ ] did you read
this and how do you read this and
[ __ ] walk down the street with a
smile on your face in no way does this
stop pollution or address the pilot
trash in the ocean it just monetizes a
global issue the whole thing traces back
to rockefeller and the dude behind NATO
of course sea Club of Rome I'm not
saying the world isn't changing I'm just
saying no one in charge is going to fix
it because the money is in charge not us
like you always say the dollar is
failing and they're going to keep
figuring out ways to suck the life out
of us no I'm what I'm saying now is we
all have to like you know we have to
figure out a way that we can do it at a
mom-and-pop level and finally address I
don't know the fact that this is our
place too I don't man now why this [ __ ]
is just so [ __ ] depressing I got a
young kid here the world that she's
going to be in is crazy anyways but the
Patriots played Monday night tonight
all right mother has new boyfriend no
boy hey Billy Billy Bob bitch-tits
a huge fan of the podcast stand up etc
recently my mom dropped a bomb on me she
dropped the bomb on me baby she'd been
married to my stepdad forever over 10
years and I always thought they had a
good marriage my stepdad is a great man
and we have always gotten along very
well about a month ago my mom calls to
tell me that she is divorcing my stepdad
Wow
she was caught in a bar hanging on
another dude by friends of my stepdad
she's been cheating with this guy for
several months oh boy needless to say I
think this is pretty [ __ ] up and my
stepdad is absolutely crushed within a
few days my mom starts hinting that she
wants me to meet him which I have no
desire to do so especially since I am
still very close with my stepdad I
expressed how I felt to my mother and
she said that when I was ready to meet
him to let her know well that was cool
at least she didn't try to force the guy
on you despite this she is still
basically trying to force me to meet him
that's not cool
sending me pictures of him telling me
what a good guy he is what we have in
common
etc wow I'm sure he's a good dude no but
this [ __ ] is still pretty fresh and it's
just weird for me my question is do you
think my mom is being a little selfish
here yeah or else she's also maybe feels
guilty for the way she got out of the
last relationship and she needs you the
love of her life her own kid to let her
know that it's okay anyways and am I
wrong to feel some sort of way no not at
all I would love to hear your thoughts
on this thank you for all you do keep
crushing and go [ __ ] yourself yeah I
think yeah you're a hundred percent in
the right and maybe you just need just
say listen I understand this guy is
important to you but you got to respect
my boundaries here you know you kind of
hit me over the head with this this is a
shock I still like the last guy you were
with and I have to process that
I'd appreciate it if you would allow me
the time I don't need to see any more
pictures of him and I will come to you
when I'm ready just basically tell them
everything just told me just tell them
tell her you know you'll meet him when
you're ready
that's a tough situation though and you
know what that's her life it's not your
life and you don't have to repeat those
mistakes all right you're a different
person so don't think that this is gonna
have any influence on your [ __ ]
relationships all right overrated
underrated dear Billy break your booze
record burn oh yeah oh yeah I'm on my
way I'm on my way what is the actual
date what I'm gonna do it I need to hit
200 368 days would be my new record so
I'll be at 341 by the N 342 343 350 357
364 three sixty-five to sixty-seven
sixty-eight oh there it is November 27th
I'll hit my new record I don't know but
I'll tell you people keep telling me how
good I look the vanity might keep me off
the [ __ ] that would be that would be
a goddamn shame for me to go right back
you know become a fat [ __ ] again I
wonder I don't want to do that all right
underrated freezer mugs great to have a
frosty glass come out of the freezer for
a refreshing cold soda four weeks so
sober good for you there you go there
you go
be careful with the soda you don't I
mean that's another thing too then you
got a [ __ ] you know I actually have
drank more soda this year than I ever
have in my life that includes when I was
a kid I was never really a fan of it I
can never I can never finish it just
made me feel like I was bloated but uh
yeah my cigar smoke and soda drinking
terrible so now I've got both of those
back under control
I got rid of all the cigars in the house
I have a humidor but there's nothing in
it and
it's been a great great thing for me so
now I look forward to smoking a cigar I
do it maybe twice a month once or twice
a month now that's back to where the
where I needed it to be all right
unrated open open bar weddings unless
that's overrated went to two open bar
weddings within the last month while
trying to get sober as tempting as it
was I still had a great time sober
people use it as an excuse to get loaded
I woke up the following day without a
nasty hangover
I got to enjoy the wedding and the
following day oh yeah all I'm telling
man you go to a wedding and you stay
sober like as the night goes on all of a
sudden you look like the catch in the
room like you got your [ __ ] together
you're like Gleason in the hustler and
everybody else is Fast Eddie Felson or
whatever his [ __ ] name is I go a
laugh I'll tell you underrated eight
hours sleep waking up feeling like a
[ __ ] champ all right I got to upload
this podcast I got to end here I got to
go swimming like the old man that I am
and go play with my lovely daughter
before these bankers and oilmen [ __ ]
destroy this goddamn planet all right go
[ __ ] yourselves and I don't know if I
don't know what to tell you about the
world those those emails really [ __ ]
upset me I don't need to hear that [ __ ]
I got to get some solar panels all right
I'll see you